[Music]
good
hello how you guys doing
all right
good man thank you that person's very
excited uh good to be in la i recently
moved to la uh from america
which
is weird when you move to l.a to get
into showbiz all your friends from back
home warn you that you're going to
become shallow and superficial but i
don't really worry about it because i
don't even talk to those friends anymore
i'm hollywood [ __ ]
you have a little l.a stage name go by
moe mandel i switch into moogs my
parents are hippies they can't name
mohan
is hindu it's indian and i'm white
if you like a dick when i call tech
support it's like i know i should know
this
don't you feel kind of bad when you call
tech support you're calling up the third
world like what's up dude if you're not
too busy fighting a civil war or washing
your clothes in the river i was
downloading porn onto my laptop
and i am frozen so
no i understand you have malaria but i
have american problems
i'm actually uh jewish but i'm jewish
kind of a weird way check it out face
and hair kind of excessively jewy yeah
and they got the uh jock body right
kind of in between a jew and a guy who
drives by in a truck and yells jew
a little bit a little bit
methamphetamines right there
and i was actually doing some european
comedy this year and i'm performing in
germany you know i found out it is still
very hard to be jewish
in germany
because it's expensive over there
oh
the euro
the euro i understand when my
grandparents got the hell out of there i
really get it now
makes sense
no it's hard to be jewish german because
you want to hate everybody you're
walking around these people killed my
people these people killed my people
then after a day you're like these
people dance to techno till 6 am this
place is awesome
you start out these nazi bastards you
bite into a sausage everybody makes
mistakes
felt like a sellout man i went to
amsterdam like i'm gonna go to the anne
frank house and have a meaningful
experience i'm gonna go to the anne
frank house then i woke up
i'm gonna get high and go to the
heineken factory cause
they are going to have way better
samples you know what i'm talking about
then whatever anne is passing out in her
little house
you really feel like an idiot though
when you're an american in europe
because like every country i went to
they had very strong opinions about
america and i had no opinions about
anyone else's country
at all
i was in sweden they're like in sweden
we say americans are like this and like
that what do you say about us i was like
is that your vikings like that's about
are you guys still boating around and
whatnot or we don't really we don't care
about you we don't i'm sorry
i'm not a very political uh comedian
obviously i don't really care about
politics everyone assumes i'm political
because i bought a used car and it
already had bumper stickers on it
i'm not political it's just very hard to
take off a bumper sticker you know i
mean you gotta scrape and peel like
screw it i'm against abortion
and i'm voting for dukakis in 88 check
that out
everyone in la is very liberal it's very
liberal town but they're very cocky
about the fact they're liberal which is
kind of obnoxious so my goal this year
is to buy a prius
so i can be the anti-prius driver like
yeah that's my prius the one with the
gun rack and the mccain sticker on the
back and the
yeah the one with the dead deer carcass
rope to the hood
wouldn't that be fun drive around the
prius throwing garbage out your window
it's a prius already helped the earth
hippie
one political issue i don't understand
at all is the uh gay marriage issue
though i understand why people care
whether you marry a man or a woman you
ever seen a couple over 65 it is very
hard to tell who is hurt
right
it's difficult like oh i think that's
the husband with the bigger titties okay
[Applause]
this seems very homophobic you know
whatever many people are homophobic i
was like dude you got to be gay yourself
or else why are you emotionally involved
in the issue i hate gays why they come
into my dreams and have sex with each
other
i start touching myself to scare them
away
but they still look like chuck norris
is that just me okay
it doesn't matter who you're having sex
so it just matters if you're doing it
well right that's what makes me nervous
because my girlfriend's great at sex and
i have no idea how good i am as a guy
you never know wish there was a way you
could know wish you could like bang a
robot and get a print out wouldn't that
be nice
that'd be nice i'm a six man i get 50 on
bread that's a nice coupon right there
you ever in that position about to sleep
with somebody and you could just tell
they're bringing way more skills to the
table than you're ready to deal with
you're getting naked she's stretching
and shadowboxing in the
corner you're taking off your pants
she's putting on a headband with a
japanese sunrise
every time i have sex with my girlfriend
i feel like the one white sprinter in
the olympics like this is
i'm bill ridiculous
thank you
great job thank you that's hilarious
thank you so much
everybody
terrific